have you ever feeling jittery restless
is your skin a little flushed could be
early signs of Star Wars fever see we're
only two weeks away from Star Wars The
Force awakens coming to the multiplex
finally and while it might seem like
you've been seeing the same footage
again and again and again the spate of
new clips and TV spots actually is
giving us a few clues that we didn't
know about first thanks to all new
footage shown recently at the American
Music Awards we know that that explosion
Rey and Finn turn away from is actually
a quad jumper it's a vehicle they were
running toward in order to escape a
first-order attack on jakku but a TIE
fighter blew it up before they could get
to it and that's the shot that we've
seen time and time again we also know
that the Finn becomes a full-on badass
not much of a mystery but at least we've
now seen him wielding a lightsaber and
manning a gun on the Millennium Falcon
second we now know that ray goes from
being the girl with the staff more on
that in a second - getting her blast on
thanks to a little assist from Han
Solo's personal Arsenal
third I don't think we've seen these
particular tracer missile from shot of
the dogfight but it's a nice touch that
grounds the usual pew pew laser cannon
fight in something that's a little bit
more analog fourth the shot of the first
order stormtrooper staring at that
freaky red sky what are they looking at
sky kind of suggests they might be
witnessing a I don't know a
demonstration of some mighty weapon and
is that the Starkiller base that they're
assembled in front of and is that maybe
why it's called the Starkiller base is
that what we're looking at only time
will tell but survey says speculative
yes
v bb-8 is bb-8 is pretty cute if you
can't make a peace with that then you
need to go grinch it up somewhere else
but wait the plot thickens just a couple
of days ago amazon france mistakenly
published the track listing for the film
soundtrack and the titles of those
compositions along with their sequence
may give us a few new clues like the
piece the girl with the staff is
completely about Rey the fact that the
title sounds so much like a line of
dialogue makes it clear that it's the
way someone is talking about her so the
mystery then is who is that is a fin or
is it huh only time will tell
also the track called kylo Ren arrives
at the battle is followed by one called
the abduction who does he abduct rumors
have said with Skywalker but from the
trailer clip that shows Kyle Lohse face
off with relic eyelet Poe Dameron
I'm going to go out on a limb and say
that Oscar Isaacs character might
actually be a decent guess and then
later in the soundtrack there is a
there's a composition that's just called
the raft arse with an exclamation point
like you can hear the jazz hands so the
question is who are the raft arcs
sounds like they're probably arrays of
creatures and it's not
his name so whoever they are we're
guessing they're not as much fun as the
ewoks speaking of new characters we
still haven't seen Lupita Nyong'o in
action as CGI character Maz Kanata we
gotta hope it's coming soon I mean
there's only two weeks left
what you started